[Music]
the top man at the Pentagon right now
says China is the biggest threat to the
u.s. acting defense secretary Patrick
Shanahan spoke with me in his first
interview at the Space symposium in
Colorado Springs where he talked up the
new space force I started by asking
Shanahan about the deaths of three
American Marines from roadside bombing
in Afghanistan Monday and a major
disconnect the Taliban is taking credit
for that attack even as the u.s. is
sitting down with Taliban leaders for
peace talks to try to end the war this
is the hardest part of my job I send my
condolences to the families and the
friends of those service members who
lost their life they gave the ultimate
sacrifice for which we can never repay
let's talk about the situation in
Afghanistan we are executing the South
Asia strategy and the South Bay Egypt
strategy really speaks to reconciliation
with the Taliban and reconciliation
comes about by putting pressure on them
we're at war
what you see are the casualties of war
in parallel there is a peace negotiation
process and probably the best
possibility for peace in 40 years is at
hand fourteen thousand US troops is your
mandate to cut troop levels there our
mandate is to execute the South Asia
strategy pure and simple it's always 14
thousand a good number for the president
we don't talk troop movements and we
don't try and talk troop levels is there
hope that this is going to come to some
resolution soon I'm hopeful I mean this
is a real possibility for peace but as I
mentioned earlier we are driving down
two tracks we're here at the Space
symposium space is reciting a big part
of what you're doing right now we have a
19 trillion dollar economy that runs on
space our military runs on space it is
vitally important and it's a critical
domain just like air land and sea the
expectation is over the next 20 years
we'll become the industry space industry
will become a trillion dollar a year
business but there's risk and danger in
space and that's really the creation of
the space force Chinese and Russians are
deploying capability that put our
economy and our military at risk in a
time of crisis critics would say that
you're just giving the US Air Force
different uniforms we're consolidating
across ten different organizations into
a single structure so we can move more
quickly in this very complex domain
what's the thing you spend the most time
on as defense secretary acting defense
secretary I should say the future how so
the ongoing operations are enormous ly
complex it's been over 30 years since
we've modernized china is modernizing we
need to as a country modernize our
military I spend more and more time
really laying the foundation and putting
that capability in place did Jim mattis
give you any advice
Jim Madison's advice was always steady
as she goes
eyes on the boat has it been hard taking
over for Jim mattis those are big shoes
to fill but we put in place the right
plan we have the right resources we're
in a period of execution does the acting
affect your job at all the fact that
you're acting defense secretary my
mother asks me this question all the
time
when are you going to be nominated and
what I tell her is it's an honor and a
privilege to serve our country and I
will serve in any capacity the president
sees fit I don't wake up in the morning
and think about whether I'm gonna be
nominated I do the job do you think your
time at Boeing is the reason that you
this has been slowed up I'm glad you
brought that up and allows me to address
it when Congress asked me
would I be open to an investigation
without hesitation I said absolutely
I'm fully cooperating with the IG first
of all when I joined the administration
I sold every financial interest I had in
the Boeing Company I want to step
further every interest in the defense
sector and this is this is a point I
want to make very clear I am NOT biased
towards Boeing I'm biased towards
performance I'm biased towards
performance for the US government for
the taxpayer and most importantly the
warfighter I'm an equal-opportunity
critic if I see under performance I call
it the way I see it that's what the
warfighter
expects and that's what they deserve so
you've never favored Boeing in your
current job I have never favored Boeing
in my current job and I never will about
the IG report just to be clear do you
think that the IG report and reaction to
it on Capitol Hill has been politically
motivated we'll see I know
I've not made any decisions in favor of
Boeing and the work I've done is to
drive waste out of the f-35 program so
we can deliver the capability our men
and women deserve and had a savings that
the taxpayers expect is Russia or China
the bigger threat to the United States
in China China's threat economically and
diplomatically I think it's time we we
address some of these issues
militarization of the South China Sea
the Communist Chinese party launching
cyberattacks against the u.s. theft of
intellectual property
and a significant expansion of military
capability it's a world we need to
confront will America ever be able to
truly protect Americans from cyber
threats from countries from individuals
we will I mean it's not tomorrow and if
you ask me what keeps me up at night
which I'm sure you're going to ask me
it's cyber what I would tell you is the
department is aggressively addressing
that threat and across not just the
Department of Defense but working on
critical infrastructure and working with
our suppliers allies and partners should
the US military be deployed at the u.s.
other more the mission down at the
border this isn't a new one for the
department we supported the Bush
administration the Obama administration
I think in the Bush administration we
had over 6,000 troops deployed the
president obviously is focused on the
border pretty extensively and because
it's degrading the situation there is
deteriorating over the weekend the
homeland security secretary here's
Nelson resigned different stories behind
the scenes about that but there was
reported tension between the president
and the secretary did you see that
firsthand I saw a lot of intensity to
solve a problem that's not tension this
is very focused effort the board is a
serious situation we're all feeling the
pressure to solve the situation down on
the border it's an emergency we have
lots of intense discussions at the White
House because these are serious issues
and they require serious attention do
you feel that the policy is going to
change now that there's a change in
leadership at the Department of Homeland
Security we've worked with the Acting
Secretary of the new acting secretary
I'm confident we'll continue to be able
to support the department and we'll
continue to solve problems this decision
about Iran and the Revolutionary Guard
designating the Revolutionary Guard and
Iran a terrorist organization does that
create problems for you and US troops on
the ground in a row
the IRGC is responsible for the death of
US service members this is a policy
decision to have non-military effects
put pressure on the Iranian economy
we're gonna continue to work in Iraq to
strengthen security forces we recognize
Iraq's sovereignty it's our role in
country to build security and we'll
continue to do that so now that Qasem
Soleimani is essentially a terrorist
will you be targeting him
we'll use sanctions and the appropriate
mechanisms that come along with the
designation as appropriate which
includes targeting someone will use
terrorists will use that as appropriate
what's your relationship with President
Trump have a good relationship with him
he's very demanding as you know and he's
very engaging when you hear critics on
TV and elsewhere say he's disconnected
he's snapped he's losing his marbles and
they say all kinds of things on
different cable channels what's your
reaction to that you sit in those
meetings how's your reaction and
interaction with the president he's
engaged he gives us the resources we
need to do our job and he supports us in
what we need to defend America we have
extraordinary bipartisan support from
Congress we have a strong strong
leadership from the White House we're
making the changes necessary to compete
and win you should have high confidence
in your military mr. secretary we
appreciate the time good thank you